foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
series people implanted an information
era and today I have Eric Schmidt thank
you for joining us and Eric is the chair
of the special competitive studies
project former CEO and chairman of
Google thanks for taking the time thank
you Brian I'll do anything I can do to
help Stanford and what you're trying to
do it's a great program we really
appreciate it so let me start by asking
a little bit about your experience at
Google so over the time you were there
what would you say is the biggest change
you noted in the industry
well there's been a lot of changes but
but one way to understand it
is that we were successful because of
the scale of the internet and the scale
of computing Network scale
and we were able to build algorithms
that scaled to billions of people
I noted with a lot with alarm that Gmail
had four billion users that's half the
planet
I'm really proud of that I remember the
day we introduced it never would I have
thought that that could have occurred
what I've learned in Tech is when you
get something that works and can scale
it can explode and that's fantastic
really exciting so one of the features
of tech that's gotten a lot of attention
is the monetization of personal data so
I'm wondering what you think is the cost
and benefits of that model of monetizing
the scale that you described well a lot
of people talk about this but they don't
speak about it accurately so the first
question that I would offer is if you
have a free service somebody's got to
pay for it now you could have
philanthropists you could have the
government you can have advertisers or
what have you at Google we were
extremely careful not to use your
personal data to sell it there are other
places some social media for example
some other search engines try this it
doesn't typically work people value
their privacy so you've got to find a
way to find affinities you know this
group and that group without violating
people's personal lives their location
and that kind of stuff so the way I
understand it so I correct me if I'm
wrong is that once people are providing
this information what they're searching
for or on social immediate what they
look at it's a way of identifying their
interests to keep them engaged and so
how should we think about the cost of
really focusing on trying to keep
people's attention so this has as it's
gone on especially in social media I
would say probably more than search
that's become a concern that we are
finding ways to just keep people engaged
in some of the ways that we keep people
engaged are not the most positive well
20 years ago we fought this question
about personal information and search
and we ultimately compromised in the
sense that The Regulators required a
certain amount of retention of
information about your searches so for
example if you're a bad person they
could get a subpoena and that sort of
thing but in general your searches are
forgotten after a while which is a good
compromise
in social media you have a different
problem that I don't think we understood
when social media came out 10 years ago
what happens now is that the AI
algorithms are so good that they can
find people just like you and connect
you and these are not people that you
would meet in normal life they're not
they don't live near you they don't go
to Stanford they didn't go to the same
College you don't know them they're not
friends and so forth and it creates
these Affinity groups which connect for
example horrific people together right
who then organize to take over the
government illegally
right so so we the good news is we're
finding Affinity groups but
unfortunately those who ignore human
nature ignore the fact that there are
badly motivated people immoral people
and people who are willing to do harm to
others and so the problem with social
media is it's both doing amazing work
collecting people who all the standard
stories of people who are suffering from
some disease and building communities
entertainment communities child care
communities all of that's all true but
it's also having this effect as well so
I'd love to think about the
responsibility that companies should
have for that and I actually I'm going
to Pivot a little bit not just and talk
about the data we have of people and the
ability to create these Affinity groups
as you describe but a large percentage
of people get their news from social
media now so according to uh Pew study
in 2021 about half of Americans get news
on social media at least sometimes so
when you think about that plus the
Affinity groups the possibility of
putting together foreign
bad people what responsibility should
organizations like
you know social media companies have for
the potential harm they can do to
society well to some degree the social
Community social media companies have
been in denial on this and I'm glad that
this discussion is underway so let's
start with some principles I was brought
up to believe in the legitimate
institutions of government and the media
in my case I grew up with two television
channels and there were only two and you
were told to believe them
today there's a lot of evidence that
people prefer to trust their friends
over institutions
and they've chosen to Define their
friends as the people that they are
friends online with
and that is the basis of the current
problem so in other words if you
fundamentally for whatever reason have
been taught or believed or correctly
believe or incorrectly believe that the
government and the legitimate
institutions of the news are out to get
you you can't trust them mainstream
media what have you without a critical
eye you just agree with that then you
trust people like you
then the algorithm finds people like you
right think of it as weaponizing you
they find you and they recruit you
so let's think about a crazy person and
my standard joke on this is they all
seem to be on some strange Farm in
Oregon you know I don't know if every
when I've looked at it it's unfair to
Oregon by the way so you've got some
crazy person in a farm in Oregon who
spews out complete crazy stuff it's
completely false
well with President Trump
it was one stop from that crazy person
to president Trump retweeting
that crazy person's thing and
legitimizing it so he should be held
responsible in my view for spreading
misinformation that he should have known
better that's my personal View
but now what really happened was
actually slightly different
this crazy person would tweet something
of using tweet but Facebook I'm just
using it as a metaphor they would
publish this information
and it would sit around and then it
would go viral in the sense that the
algorithm would discover that it was
interesting
and the algorithm would boost it so one
way to say it is a different way of
asking this to say Eric what do you
believe in terms of speech I am
absolutely committed to free speech by
adults and I Define that as you get to
say what you say even if I disagree with
it and I have to at least acknowledge
you have the right to say it I do not
believe in boosting of said speech
without liability
so the problem is that the platforms are
are also responsible
for the spread of the misinformation
many of them have been in denial on this
but the fact of the matter is their
algorithms are so good that they find
something and we know for example that
emotional content is spread seven times
faster than reason content let me say it
emotionally I want my country back I
thought my country was a country of
Reason discourse good arguments strong
principles fights around uh greatness
and instead it's turned into crazy
person rumor falsehood misinformation I
want to go back to the earlier model
yes now that's that's the question how
do we get there so would you you talk
about liability would you do you think
that the company should be liable for
this do you think the company should
um for the January 6th event should they
be held liable like where where is
responsibility
so this is a really hard problem and the
reason is that if you start thinking
about it and I thought about it a lot
all of the roads end up to something
which is completely unacceptable
which is the Department of Internet
regulation it's not going to work
so we need sensible changes in social
media let me give you some examples
we allow people
legally age 13 and up it should really
be 16 and up because we protect minors
in society but we don't protect them
from social media which is where all the
terrible stuff in my view is as well as
good stuff
we need to make that change
another thing is that we need to know
how these algorithms work
and not to scare you but it's going to
get much much worse
and the reason it's going to get much
worse is that the AI algorithms are
getting so good and I'll give you an
example
I'm a well-known figure I hope I'm a
good person you can decide for yourself
someone who doesn't like me or for
whatever reason takes my likeness and
turns me into a racist sexist spigot
and has my voice
and people will believe that I said that
and it's repugnant to me what right do I
have
we don't have an answer to that we have
to have some rules or way for me to get
that under control because it's a use of
my likeness it's worse in commercial
speech if it's interesting that in
social media most of the revenue comes
from advertisers and advertisers are
intelligent and they don't want to be a
ju to be adjacent to this kind of hatred
so one way to say it would to say that
when you have a a feed that is supported
by advertising you have a commercial
responsibility to the advertisers and
that they can push back on the platforms
these are examples
if you know who's on the platform
another thing we don't know using
various forms of ID verification both
for age but also are they and by the way
I'm not suggesting the end of anonymity
I think anonymity is very important do
we still have anonymity well we do in
the following sense
um when you get on an Uber driver when
you get into an Uber or Lyft or what
have you do you personally know the
driver have you met the driver before
typically not
in fact I seldom know the the real name
of the driver but I trust that that
driver man or woman has been
validated secured investigated what have
you that it's a trustworthy momentary
interaction
I think that we could build algorithms
in social media which allow you to have
the anonymity which I think is important
for privacy and for the ability for
speech and to say what you think
especially in cases where you've been
victimized but also having the system
underneath
know who you are and furthermore I think
we should have a rule that there's that
you have to declare when when it's a bot
as opposed to a human because I'm in
favor of remember free speech of humans
and not Bots and the other thing that we
have to do is we have to have a marker
technically a watermark on where did the
content come from
if you know that it's a real human
if you know how the algorithm works and
you know that the content is genuine it
was not synthesized then you have an
approximation for truth right because
then the platform can say this is a
human this is what they said this is
what they generated and this other stuff
we're not so sure it's entertaining it's
interesting the one that shocked me so
I'm clear I was very good friends and on
the board of Apple with Steve Jobs there
is an interview with a site called
podcast.ai that just came out which is
an interview today with Joe Rogan
interviewing Steve Jobs on the matters
today in his voice now I love Steve Jobs
and I miss him terribly it sent shivers
down my spine
that's what we're confronting and I can
tell you from my many years at Google
doing things involving YouTube and so
forth and so on
people react they react emotionally it's
dangerous it can lead to crowds and
assaults and harm we've got to get a
sensible structure and I propose knowing
who the people are knowing where the
content front came from appropriate age
limitations and understanding how the
algorithms are I think those are
sensible and they don't require
regulating speech which we're not in
favor of yeah so I'm wondering about the
anonymity that you're describing so I
think if I understand correctly the
anonymity you're describing is when I
say something the people I'm saying it
to might not know who I am but because
they trust the platform because the
safeguards you have that you're
describing are in place it's known
somewhere I am there's a verification
that I am a person that you're a human
being saying it's a true human but I
think today and I'll speak for myself a
bit the anonymity I worry about is the
corporations and knowing who I am right
because of the way the data is collected
the way that data has been used the fear
of breaches of that data so in in that
in your scenario are you asking people
to to trust the organizations
I think you I'm sorry to be blunt Brian
I think you lost that battle
the fact of the matter is the
corporations in order for these
algorithms to work they know a great
deal of information it is crucial that
those corporations keep that information
proprietary we know technically how to
do that
and if a corporation were to violate
your trust in the way that you're
describing
there should be penalties uh Financial
penalties you should leave the platform
there should be regulatory penalties
when I was running Google I always
worried that there would be some data
breach thank God there never was that
would harm people in the way you're
describing sensible leadership
understands the point you're making and
they can put the Protections in place
and what role does government have in
this so the way I mean thus far we're
talking about it as the organizations
should put these safeguards in place
they have the technical ability to do it
but it seems like every other day
there's a breach yeah right and and so I
wonder how much faith we should put in
organizations and where is the role of
government and what you're describing
I'll now show you my own prejudices when
you look at the really top technical
companies the the really well-run ones
which include Google and its competitors
and so forth you don't have those
breaches
the cost to them is too high and their
Engineers are really good the breaches
that you're describing are from systems
that were built a long time ago in
technologies that aren't very good
they're running down rev platforms and
you have to assume you see this in the
government all the day most of the
government systems you have to assume
have been breached because the
government is quite incompetent building
powerful new platforms they're just not
good at it and unfortunately I'm sorry
to say this I think your primary danger
is your government information getting
leaked through some sort of Chinese or
adversarial attack which is obviously
not okay and the liability is high
um I've been involved in a number of of
analyzes of these breaches
um and when you have a leadership which
is sort of asleep at the wheel they grow
up really fast when this happens and
they do in fact put the safeguards in
place and so what should the
relationship then be between government
and these kind of private tech companies
well it's easy to complain about the
private cab companies and
um
let's break them up they're too big they
have too much power
but they're as a general rule honest
well-run and they do what they say and
the reason that they're honest and will
run do what they say is if they don't
they get sued to death
the board of directors get sued the CEOs
get sued
so if you propose regulation then do so
in a way in the spirit of making it
better
there's no question that there's content
that is bad harmful
try to write down the rules I've tried
to do this so let's say we I don't like
this kind of thing and this kind of
thing and this kind of thing and I write
it down okay now this is a democracy do
we all agree by the way the great news
is we all agree against child porn we
all agree there's no no one I know of in
favor of it
but write it about adult porn you won't
get agreement write it about drugs or
alcohol or other controversial things
one of the things to understand
and I'll say this in a historical
context is that we all complain about
freedom of speech
but the fact of the matter is freedom of
speech is that the essence of how
America works and the complicated
trade-offs I I was not aware of all the
restrictions on speech it turns out that
you can say some things but there's
plenty of things you can't say right you
can't threaten people you can't threaten
to kill them there's all sorts of issues
around defamation and so forth and so on
I think those vehicles are there I
forgot one more thing to add
the industry runs on something called
the dmca
and the dmca was done I think in 1994 I
was there when it was all happening and
it basically exempts the platform from
liability
there is a lawsuit which curiously
involves Google
it says in front of the Supreme Court
where there is a possibility that the
dmca exemption will be narrowed
if that occurs and no one knows what the
Supreme Court is going to do of course
that could Usher in a reason to modify
that law right in some way and that'll
be a great opportunity to have this
debate of where this liability is
I want to be truthful and say
there's clearly a speaker but there's
but the publisher in this case the
service the online system has some
culpability in spreading it you just
have to decide what the penalty for bad
culpability is the dmca says you can do
what you want as long as you use the
dmca protection that's going to get
questioned well I'm looking forward to
those conversations but I know you're
also a proponent of private public or
private government cooperation so what
what does that look like what what is
what kind of relationship do you what
kind of relationships do you like
but one of the things that I I learned
you know as a technical person you don't
have time to study history so I guess
you learn it later
is that there's a really long history in
America of the three branches that I
care about which are not the government
side it's universities the private
sector and the government
the universities produce here at
Stanford extraordinary achievements I
mean look at what has been achieved in
America the engine of the world all of
the top universities started off here I
can go on and on and on about the
greatness of America
look at the business side Venture
Capital the extraordinary Creations that
have occurred which I benefited from and
look at good regulation from the
government as an example let's look at
operation warp speed under a Republican
president
operation warp speed because of the
emergency of the situation of covid
guaranteed the product to buy the
product of companies that took huge
risks not knowing if the product was
going to work that's a case where the
scientists work together with the
business world and the and the
government to respond to a critical
thing we know how to do this we claim
that we're all capitalists we claim that
we're all whatever we are but the fact
of the matter is it's intertwined I was
as a graduate student on an NSF and
DARPA Grant I'm eternally grateful for
the government to give me the money to
learn the things that I needed to do to
become successful as as I have been
I needed the government to give me that
money that was the only way place to get
it thank God they did it and by the way
it wasn't the letters like fifteen
thousand dollars a year it was a good
deal for the US compared to the taxes
that we pay now you see my point so if
you if you look at with a more
enlightened model
right it's getting that cycle without
the rhetoric working well another
example more recently is The Challenge
from China and if you look at the chips
act technically yusica
on a bipartisan basis we were able to
get 250 billion dollars a huge amount of
money over five or ten years depending
on which part of it you look at
allocated to the advancement of
competitiveness against China in key
National Security areas
now the Republicans did it for national
security reasons the Democrats did it
for national security reasons and other
reasons the universities are doing
because they want the money right the
businesses really need the money because
they want to compete with China in
something as important as semiconductors
which are the most complicated things
that are built on the planet
so that's another good example and it
took two years of negotiation it's a
democracy it's a mess and so forth I'm
very proud to have played a very small
role in making that happen yeah I want
to talk a little bit about National
Security but before I get there I'm
curious why don't you think people
understand the role that government
plays and the innovation of this country
so it's as if it's all Private Industry
and what you're talking about and I
think people don't fully appreciate
often is how big a role the government
plays in allowing things like Google to
take place because of the infrastructure
that's built the support that it
provides for the new ideas but let's
think about it did you come here by some
form of GPS map navigation
all right thank God the Air Force in the
90s launched those satellites and thank
God the government actually allowed
those satellites to be used in an
accurate way initially it wasn't
remember they were it was randomized and
that enabled the sensors which are on
phones which ultimately enabled these
enormous geo-based apps now how long did
that take 30 years what was the origin
of Google
right Larry and Sergey founded it well
actually there's a story before that
there was an NSF Grant in the mid 90s
that that thought about building an
index and the money by the way came to
Stanford and a number of other places
think about self-driving cars right
which I'm still waiting for by the way
the the DARPA Grand Challenge right I
was part of a challenges and we we had
meetings in 2004 2005 here at Stanford
right in order to do that so so the
facts are
that van of our Bush who was a hero of
world war time when when World War II
ended he took all of his wartime money I
guess I don't exactly understand it
worked but had all this excess money and
he used it to fund basic science
we are here today in this gorgeous place
with all of this technology because of a
single guy who said I'm just taking the
money and giving it to basic research
we'll see what happens
that's the courage of these leaders now
he of course is dead but he's a true
hero we need to acknowledge that our
predecessors took the political and
Financial Risk to create the environment
when you walk around the Stanford campus
you see all these buildings they have
names on it of dead people those dead
people gave the money okay you should be
thankful you should you should say oh my
God I'm so happy that way back when they
had enough money that they had the
foresight to make this comfy place for
me to do these amazing things we need to
acknowledge the history and do you think
the government should play a bigger role
should it be more prominent I I worry
about
um the decay of the vibrancy of the
democracy and one potential issue is
that people don't appreciate the role
that government plays in making their
life as great as it is so I also
appreciate that private industry has a
significant role to play and obviously
universities have a role to play but I I
worry that the role of government is
lost or underappreciated do you think
that the partnership is somehow becoming
unbalanced
um it's always been precarious
so people forget that in the 50s we had
the McCarthy hearings in the 60s we had
the Vietnam War right these are people
weren't alive during that period our
country is always in some form of crisis
and the Brilliance of America
is that American the American the
creativity and the entrepreneurial of
the people
gets through it so the reason to answer
your question in a strange way is to say
we're here because of the Excellence of
the quality of the people and the
Educational Systems and the motivations
and the incentives and that applies to
the government and the universities and
business and yes it's a mess
now with respect to answer your question
specifically
the problem with government is it's
always behind
and it's designed to be that way it's
deliberative it's supposed to take a
while if you want something done fast do
it in the private sector
the private sector will always operate
quickly the best model is as follows the
private sector has access to Capital
with risk and focus I'm not talking
about handouts and The Regulators are
watching
and when something gets out of whack
which does occur the regulator steps in
at that point that's called enlightened
regulation
there's a tendency I'll give you my
favorite example
in AI which is where I'm sending most of
my work now
I was fortunate enough to leave the lead
the National Security Commission for AI
for the government the US government and
we produced a report which I'm very
proud of
the whole team
Europe
built a report
about regulation
they didn't have half the report being
what would it take to get the money and
the people in the organization was we
were focused they just focused on
regulation so Europe will be an
excellent regulator of stuff that they
don't invent
the problem with regulation is the name
is regulation it should be invent and
regulate it should be promote and
regulate it should be Economic
Development and jobs and regulation
if the regulator thinks their job is to
regulate then they will over regulate
these are complicated trade-offs
you can't get it perfect there will
always be I'll give you an example my
favorite another example
if I told you that self-driving cars
could cut the number of deaths in the in
the US by half you'd say that's great
it's on the order of 35 000 car deaths a
year so approximate the number is
increasing by the way unfortunately
these are cars are very safe
let's say we could cut that by half
you would say that's a pretty good those
are lives families an enormous toll of
car accidents I don't know if you've had
anyone die in a car accident it's
horrific
one of my friends did it's just terrible
now go to a regulator and say
we're going to cut the deaths in half
and we want you to approve this new
thing they're not going to do it they're
going to say I want you to cut all the
deaths and I say
I want to get to zero but all I get to
is half right now
is the regulator going to prove you not
a chance
it's a case where you have a false
trade-off if the goal is to reduce
deaths just use death says because
that's obviously terrible we're going to
reduce deaths then it's different from
we want to eliminate them obviously we
want to eliminate them the way we
eliminate them is we reduce them if you
had a zero tolerance policy for deaths
in test pilots you never have airplanes
now obviously it's horrific
right but they're doing something risky
for our benefit and they're taking a
risk you have to figure out that balance
yeah I mean I find I always that example
comes with quite a bit the self-driving
cars I always find it interesting
because I think the issue there is
responsibility so it's the perception of
like yeah you cut it in half but who's
now responsible for those those deaths
that we made I'll I'll give you my my
joke about this so I don't know about
you but when I drive in California I
have occasionally done that California
rolling stop you know the kind not quite
so imagine you're in your self-driving
car and it has learned from you to do
this because it's a learning machine and
the cop pulls you over and the cop says
um sir you know you did a rolling stop
and I say officer I did not and he said
the officer says who did and the car
says I did and the officer says why and
said the car says I don't know
truthfully everyone's everyone's being
truthful in that scenario
where's the liability
you know the officer is trying to do his
job here's her job excuse me
I am being truthful is the car liable is
the drive reliable is the training
liable
is the manufacturer liable
we don't know we have to figure these
things out but I'll tell you the world
will be safer with self-driving cars
because self-driving cars don't get
drunk right a lot of accidents occur
late at night people are tired whatever
they don't get tired they don't get
drunk right and it's criminal that we
have all of these deaths today because
we've not been able to find a path
through this no I agree and I think it
ends up a lot of it ends up being
dealing with the liability issues if we
got if we have the technology that's
good enough there's still going to be
mistakes and the liability issues are
significant and people I think that
people maybe don't trust that the
corporations will benefit financially
will internalize the risks there's a lot
of distrust about corporations in this
regard and it's it's fine
this is the role for government
incorporate I mean everyone knows the
story of mistreatment sitting in an
airline seat that's why the airline
industry has a regulatory body
right there's a passenger Bill of Rights
we have to find that balance those and
by the way in the airline industry these
things are litigated forever it's
complicated how many hours can you be
held without water and food and so forth
and everyone's acutely aware of those
rules how long have we had these rules
in place you know tens and tens of years
and we've worked them out so I do want
to come back to the National Security
Commission on artificial intelligence
that you mentioned could you say a
little bit about what was in the report
what the goals were well we we delivered
our final report a little bit more than
about a year and a half ago and we
worked on it for three years during the
pandemic which is very bizarre because
we did it remotely and the question was
is AI important from a national security
perspective and how are we doing
the rough summary is it's really
important because of the issues that you
described and we made a secret set of
recommendations the first was more
research money which has occurred thank
goodness the second one was more
collaboration with our domestic our
Democratic Partners which is in the
process of working on another one was
very very sophisticated training for
government which has not occurred yet
but is really important
another one is to stay ahead of China
with respect to semiconductors we called
in our report that we needed to stay two
generations ahead of China in
semiconductors a generation is defined
as a process cycle
and we said it would be really nice if
they stayed at 14 nanometers lower is
better and we would get to five four
which is where we are now
it looks like China is now at the seven
nanometer uh seven so they're they're
already ahead of where we wanted to
which is not good however the recent
actions by the Trump and bite
Administration to limit access to what
is called Ultra euv technology which is
a very specialized product that's
handled by a specific company in
Netherlands called asml looks like it
will hold them back and that will buy us
a year or two the summary is what we
said is that the United States is ahead
that China is the primary competitor
here they're very smart and they're
moving quickly and they're a short
period of time behind us we also in the
report reported on some other things we
said that it looks like China is ahead
of us in new energy they make most of
the batteries and so forth it looks like
China is ahead of us ahead of us in
financial services these are online
banking those kinds of things these are
very important we know they're ahead of
us in surveillance
and we also made a point that these new
platforms that we're all building AI
based need to reflect American values
and when I talk about American values I
mean Democratic Values the values of
privacy Freedom lack of surveillance
Independence
it's easy for these Technologies to be
misused in a totalitarian state and we
expressly say that the Technologies need
to be developed in the context of
American values and you know what I'm
talking about yeah and how do we ensure
that because the totalitarian states can
misuse them but certainly so can
Democratic states and obviously private
companies so how do you think about the
liability associated with the incredible
power that might be Unleashed by more
sophisticated AI like again who's
responsible for that
um I'll give you an example from a long
time ago when an engineer came in and
said well I figured out a way to predict
where your friends will be and show you
when you're going to meet
oh my God you're tracking everyone and
and at the time they're in Sergey were
having fun with me and they said oh
that's a great idea they were joking
and we eventually solved this problem by
allowing you to misstate where you are
where you were
it allowed the system to be inaccurate
with respect to something as sensitive
as your location now this is again a
long time ago but it's an example where
if you phrase the question correctly you
can solve it
private companies in practice do know
where you are I'm sorry to say that the
telephone company because of 9-1-1 knows
exactly where you are but that
information is highly regulated
and I think we'll say the same thing
here this is a case where things
involving your person your identity
another example is face recognition is
largely illegal in Europe and in a
number of states in America it's illegal
and as you know it's commonplace in
China face recognition very very
dangerous if misused for obvious reasons
stop think about stalking alone
and so I I love the example of um when
they came to you and said hey we're
going to give this probably going to
make this program it's going to tell you
where all your friends are when you're
going to meet one I love the story that
you didn't want that to happen like you
had it from your friends but more when
you think about that going forward and
what can be produced I mean you
described it as your you three in the
room and figuring out how not for it to
not be damaging but what happens when
that person is not in the room what
happens when this private company sees
immense possibility financially in doing
this I guess are we relying on
the good intentions of Private Industry
here we're we're we're relying on the
democratic system
regulation and lawsuits I can assure you
that if somebody brought out a tool
in America that had inside of that
surveillance of the nature that you're
describing they would be sued to death
there is a great concern over Chinese
products in America which may or may not
be doing that it is enormous concern
regulatory concern political concern
over that I don't know if it's true but
I think the good news about the concern
is it's a well-expressed one
I'm much more concerned about the ones
that we don't know are coming
the my favorite example with this is I
did not understand I Eric did not
understand that the tribalism
that occurs because of social media
matching would become as powerful as it
is and I'm not making a political
statement this is true on the left and
the right every race every sex every
every people we're all at some level
guilty of tribalism do you know why it's
in our nature as humans
we try to overcome it I want to be a
great American before I'm a great
whatever I am but I choose that and I
want that back
and I wonder if we're on our way back to
that and how do we get back there is it
the again I'm what I'm really so
interested in in all these issues all
these topics is the relative
responsibility of Private Industry and
the government and
um the power it's not just
responsibility because we can say as a
people the responsibility lies here or
there but where is Power life who's
making those decisions well in our
system the companies have a lot of power
but the powerful companies have a lot of
detractors and a lot of people looking
at them I was fortunate to work with two
principled Founders we spent every day
talking about these questions at the
time as we worked it through and I'm
very very proud of them for founding the
company with those values now you can
debate them but from my perspective the
values were set and we did we had a
principle of do no evil now
there wasn't a book that said what evil
was but the principle allowed people to
say
I think that's evil
I remember I thought it was a joke you
know marketing you know you know
companies are slogans and I'm sitting in
a room in a tiny little the building
when Google was founded
and this particular engineer
there was a proposal which at the time
involved Mis reusing the advertising
money in a particular way a small
company he pounds his table like this
and he says that's evil
and I go like oh my God an evil you know
evil apparency and then there was this
food fight
over was it evil or not and he canceled
the project he managed to get it killed
by his single pounding of the table and
I still remember it because it was true
so what I learned was when you get the
right value system with really smart
people and the value system is important
so if you're run by a psychopath I'm not
alleging anyone's a psychopath but if
you're run by a psychopath who doesn't
care then bad stuff happens but you need
the right Founders and you need the
right board and you need the right
regulatory structure to support it and I
and to be clear there's this permanent
now criticism of the tech which I think
is just industrial I think they just
raise money on it and I think it's
misfounded
um there's a set of senators for example
who are well known to be opposed to
everything
well the fact of the matter is we are
providing as our industry a great Public
Service my position is we welcome
intelligent regulation understand how we
work understand how the algorithms work
and help us do it the right way
sure there's stuff that you don't like
on YouTube tell me how to get rid of it
I they get millions of videos a day
right show me how we don't have a way of
doing human review we don't know exactly
how to build algorithms to fully detect
it the moment we notice it we take it
down if you have a better idea that's
the best we've come up with the
alternative is to shut down YouTube
which would be horrific since YouTube is
the primary tool for education and
entertainment for most people in America
well given all we discuss is that my
final question is as you look into the
future what are your hopes and what are
your fears
well I am more hopeful and more fearful
than I have ever been
and I'm more hopeful for the following
reason
I wrote a book with Dr Kissinger on this
called the age of AI
and I'm more hopeful
that these Technologies in AI will bring
out forms of intelligence which will
advance Solutions and cures to the
things that have bedeviled Humanity for
Generations
cures for diseases that have been a good
example I'm very proud of is Alpha fold
which was done by a subsidiary of Google
called deepmind where 200 million of the
proteins that exist in the world were
mapped this is a huge change in biology
it's a Nobel Prize in my opinion in my
opinion worthy achievement I can give
you example after example the ability to
educate every child in the world
with good information think about all
these people who are smart and hungry
but they don't have what you and I have
had right all they have is a a candle
and some kind of dumb phone but that's
their hope I'm so proud of that
I'm also on the negative side
extraordinarily concerned about the
change of perception and reality
from your birth from my birth we were
taught as babies and growing up to
believe our eyes and our ears these
systems will be able to create false
realities those false realities could be
manipulated for good it could be you
know Mother Teresa and Alfred or it
could be horrific right we have a choice
on how those things emerge we are still
in charge
we have to be honest when you have bad
and it's a shock but there's evil people
in the world and they invade countries
and they kill people and so forth if
they get in charge of this technology
they can do a lot of damage
we have to responsibly discuss the
dangers of these Technologies figure out
ways cleverly to limit this impact while
getting the extraordinary
achievements in biology chemistry new
materials quantum theory all of these
things which will change the world so
much more quickly than in my generation
for you and your children and your
grandchildren well I hope I hope it
works out that way but thanks so much
for taking the time to talk to me okay
we appreciate it we appreciate it
um so our conversation next time will be
January 23rd it'll Air at 6 30 p.m on
Pacific time and we'll continue our
exploration of tech and government I'll
be joined by Cade crockford director of
the technology for Liberty program at
the ACLU and Susie Allegra legal data
privacy expert and author of freedom to
think protecting a fundamental human
right in the digital age thanks
[Music]
thank you